breaking news from mexico city and it is
not good where the collapse of an
elevated train track
has killed at least 23 people and
injured dozens more
the train is part of one of the busiest
subway systems in the world
rescue operations were dramatically
delayed overnight
one car was left dangling in the air and
officials say there may still be more
people inside
manuel bohrkus reports on the sudden
collapse it happened right underneath
the train
security cameras captured the exact
moment the metro train plunged onto a
busy road
trapping at least one of the cars below
under the rubble
rescuers rushed the injured to nearby
hospitals
that's the mayor of mexico city claudia
scheinbaum announcing
that children are among the dead this
video shows what remains of the train
partially suspended from the overpass
dozens of rescuers frantically searched
through the rubble for victims
but their effort was briefly stopped
after the train was deemed unstable
and in danger of falling even though
multiple people were still trapped
inside
a crane was eventually brought to the
site to stabilize the train carriages
so the teams could resume their work
desperate friends and relatives of
people believed to be on the train
gathered
around the crash site
oscar lopez says he is searching for his
friend who is six months pregnant
he says police and paramedics haven't
told him anything
the accident happened on one of the
city's newest train lines which runs
partially above ground
but has had some structural issues
including needing repairs a couple of
months after its construction
mexico's prosecutor's office says it
will investigate
the railway collapse for cbs this
morning manuel pajorquez
miami